this week 48 Hours investigates one of
America's oldest cold cases just over
four decades ago a young mother from
upstate New York was brutally killed but
something about her death didn't sit
right with investigators nevertheless
the so-called Brighton acts murder case
remained unsolved until now 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty has the
story
on February 19 1982 Jim Krause says he
came home to find his wife Kathy dead in
bed with an ax in her head and his three
and a half-year-old daughter Sarah alone
but unharmed inside the house valuables
were scattered as if by a burglar but
retired Brighton police detective Mark
Liberatore and his partner detective
Steve hunt say nothing was taken this
burglar was staged police say it was
staged to cover up Kathy's murder and
that the evidence pointed to Jim
krausnick but krausnic denies it so
you're saying that this man snapped One
Night in his life and puts an ax in his
wife's head yep yeah
you can watch Aaron Moriarty's report
the Brighton acts murder on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 Central right
here on CBS and on our streaming service
Paramount Plus